what do you regret what people would
have done differently
oh that whole that whole scene is with
me in the pink nightgown i was mortified
i was mortified and like i will never
live that down i'm ashamed of it
okay
kimba kim bali i have to say it like
kimbally
you are a 90-day newbie so describe to
me your journey so far how would you sum
it up
well it's been crazy because i'm really
before the show i was a very very
private person you know like i went to
work every day took care of my mom you
know
just my normal life and now
it is so crazy i have i just got
verified and then it's like everywhere
yeah girl everywhere i go i swear
everywhere i go i get recognized so i've
learned i have to wear concealer
everywhere i go and
give those dark circles boy but it's
been a really good journey i've had some
little moments you know but it's been
it's been fun and it's been i'm very
grateful to tlc i'm very grateful and
you know to ushman as well he's one that
put me on this platform you know but
it's been it's been crazy i was at sea
world um my birthday was saturday and i
went to seaworld friday and we had to
leave we had to leave because people
were just like recording me and i'm like
okay stop
okay you mentioned that it was usman's
idea for you to join the show or for you
to join the show with him how did he
approach you about that and what made
you say yes i was actually driving to
work one day and he was like tlc is
going to call you today i was like wait
what
i pulled over
and i was like no like i don't want to
do this like because my life i have a
good life you know and i i take care of
myself and everything and
then i thought about it and i was like
you know what i'm 50 years old like why
not like why not you know like why not
put our story out there why not so
i did it took me like a month a month
and a half and then i did my first like
casting interview and i was like okay
they were like we love you like your
personality is just crazy yeah
yeah so that's how we approached it and
i mean i felt like for me
it was showing my love for him you know
and that's how i felt about the whole
thing with both of us so when i spoke to
him he mentioned that initially he
wanted to bring zara on the show
but they broke up so did you know about
that i actually wanted to go
on tv with zara but because of some of
my reasons i decided not to go on on
on
on tv
did you know that that was his plan to
first bring zara on the show i did not i
did not
how do you feel about that do you have
any feelings um i felt like a second
option i'm not gonna lie to you i felt
totally like a second option you know
and it hurt it hurt me so bad when i
found all this stuff out i can't even
you saw
you saw what people fail to realize
is and i want to make this clear i
wasn't mad he was in a relationship
i was mad that when i told him i loved
him and i stopped dating myself because
i was needing to i was doing i had a
little friend with benefits thing going
on you know and
when i stopped that because i told him i
was catching feelings for him or
whatever he should have told me at that
point that he was in a relationship i
would have never in my life pursued
anything
with him i would have never i would have
just stopped it we could have just been
cool you know like hey what's up like my
homie or something you know and he did
not and he was wrong for that
boy's girlfriend
i want to get into a fan question
here we go okay yeah okay so biedra says
quote i just got the fact that kim said
she sold your boy's girlfriend not
usements was it that she was in love
with his image
what's your response to that at first at
first i was in love with this you know
he's a celebrity i was in love with that
you know but once like i said all these
talks we had and we talked like morning
till night okay i fell in love with
gusman like i i know who ousman is as a
person but i said it because i never
called him soldier boy like once i got
to know him i would just call him usman
you know because in even one of the
other episodes i went up to him i think
they were
we were with his um badness and slam tea
and i was like soldier boy and he was
like you never call me that cuz i don't
i don't i didn't call him that you know
people are a little bit confused about
how big of a celebrity usman really is
so you you perceive him as a celebrity
is he really that big in nigeria
yes and i feel because everybody laughs
when i say international superstar usman
umar aka soulja boy he loved when i said
that but
he is known in other countries and he's
really well known where he's from you
know and he it's known and they think
because of the show he is known in
different countries you know and he does
use it as a platform to get his music
out you know i think he's a celebrity so
i mean hey that's all that matters right
yeah yeah is there any was there any
point where you felt as if usman was
using you
to further his career
as far as like youtube being on tv
together honestly to god i don't feel
that he used me for anything i don't
feel that way okay and it might be the
perception of other people and that's
fine everybody's entitled to their
opinion but nobody knows like like
how close him and i really were you know
we were extremely close you know so
nobody understands that part thank you
so much
no
p.s fight no no no no no no oh wait okay
let's talk about the money you bought
him a ps5 macbook and that gold soldier
boy chain
what's your response to viewers who feel
as if you were trying to buy useman's
love please thank you for asking me this
okay
i don't need to buy a man's love for
anything i don't need to do that okay i
didn't need to do that i and any of
anybody my friends my son anybody will
tell you everything i do and you just
said everything comes from my heart okay
i like to make other people happy i just
said i love that i love i'm a giver i'm
just a giving kind of woman you know i
don't know about now anymore but i'm a
giver so the playstation 5 actually was
not that expensive i don't want to say
how i got it but i used some of my
little restaurant manager charm and i
talked the guy down to
150 200 over uh
oh under the price okay okay under the
price so yes so i and it wasn't it was
not that expensive it was i swear to god
it wasn't i wouldn't have paid 2 000 or
even a thousand for it i just wouldn't
have done that okay the macbook the only
reason i got on the macbook is like it
was like two weeks or something before
we went to
dan's bar we were arguing on the phone
about something and he hits his music
studio and he had it on top of his car
and he drove off and it fell and
somebody ran over it and i felt so bad
because i was the one that like started
the argument you know so that's why the
soldier points this yes it is real gold
for everybody who asked because
everybody asked me that um that was that
was that was a birthday present that's
just who i am you know and i and i
i feel i don't need to bri i didn't need
to bribe i didn't buy him as bribe gifts
like what the hell is that like how do
you
that's crazy like i don't need to bribe
somebody to be with me i did it because
i'm a good person and honestly and and
anybody will tell you that like even my
son was like yo like he got a ps5 you
know but i helped
my them yeah and i helped jamal with
things too you know what i mean and my
biggest thing is to help like to make
people smile that's my biggest thing i'm
a caregiver at heart and it's one of my
it's a blessing and it's a curse you
know what i mean but for everybody out
there i don't need to bribe somebody for
sex that's gross ew
okay well speaking of that watching
yourself back what surprised you the
most about your behavior
what do you regret what you would have
done differently
oh that whole that whole scene with me
in the pink nightgown well why don't you
want to have sex with me though i don't
understand
we will have sex
i apologize for it on my social media
once i saw it back and i would never in
my life
that's just
it was so bad and and the criticism i
got for that like even now i still get
it right and i've apologized and i've
put it to bed that was good i'll put it
to bed but
but i feel
i was mortified i embarrassed myself i
embarrassed usman i embarrassed my son
you know
and the crazy thing was i was drinking a
lot and i'm not using alcohol as excuse
but i had like three bottles of
champagne because i was nervous i was
really nervous about like you know this
young guy and here i am 50 years old i'm
like hey you know i was nervous
but the way i acted i was mortified i
was mortified and like i will never live
that down i don't think and i
i got a lot of people that were like
uh victims of like sexual you know
assault and all that and i i i'm ashamed
of it um if i could go back and change
one thing i would change that another
thing i would change is calling zara
[ __ ]
because i'm a woman and if you call me a
[ __ ] i'm going to smack you across your
face so i did do an apology for that as
well and i felt bad and nobody has to
tell me to do these things you know what
i'm saying like i drew him from my heart
and i was like damn because that was
it's not her fault it's his fault so i
had so much confidence when i got here
and everything and now it's just like
it's just gone we as women
i i understand right sometimes we place
our self-worth
in the hands of the wrong person in the
hands of a man
do you feel as if you place too much of
your self-worth in useman's hands
i feel
like i did i feel like i did
but
that's the whole thing with being on a
show nobody understands what he's
telling me or what he's texting me i
didn't go down there not knowing he
wasn't going to kiss me i didn't go down
there not knowing we really didn't say
did he say we're going to kiss and we're
going to do all that or did i mean
like yeah we use certain terms but he
was that's how it was it wasn't that's
what pissed me off so much about finding
out about this relationship like you
were sitting there flirting with me like
i mean
you know like who like it was crazy and
when i got there and found it i was like
i knew about the sleeping in the
separate rooms and i was totally okay
with that because nobody looks at it
from my point of view right what if i
would have met him in person and been
like ew
i mean like
okay you're shorter than me or you know
what if what if i wouldn't have been
physically attracted to him you know
what i'm saying
but now
my self-worth is everything to me my
confidence is everything to me and i
have that now i have it back and it's
easier said than done i mean like i told
you i'm a woman men go through it too i
feel you but that was something that was
you know it was hard to watch because
yeah and it would be hard
yeah
depending on the way the relationship
was going you would feel good about
yourself or you would feel you would the
way you described it was i won or i lost
i lost
yeah and that was a joke too and it was
a total joke because before i went to
zanzibar we would like talk or whatever
and you know he called me potential or
whatever and i thought it was funny i
didn't think it was anything like you
know i didn't think it was that bad and
then
and then um so i said i told him i said
yeah i said if if we become
or get in a relationship i was like i'm
gonna just be like hashtag i won it was
it's totally a joke everybody's entitled
to their opinion i'm not saying they're
not but nobody sees the full thing
nobody sees the text where he was
telling me things and you know nobody
sees all that they just see me being
this desperate chick you know with no
confidence and but nobody's seeing like
he led me on totally we
i saw it yeah i think that was clear um
another fan question
kiki says
kiki kiki says i thought kim was down
for usman having multiple wives is that
still the case
i am down for usman to have a second
wife okay but
he needs to tell me about it you know
keep me in the dark you know that's his
culture i'm not going to be here and
sitting there going to a fertility
clinic and all that i'm done okay i just
turned 50
there's i wash my hands you know but
yeah i mean i'm really realistic that
way i know i've raised my son i don't i
don't you know that's his life but i
respect his culture i respect his
religion and and but he has to tell me
about it first don't keep it a secret
you have to tell me you know you
mentioned your son first of all your son
is so cute
thank you he's a beautiful man yes
i get so many dm's about him it's crazy
it's so crazy okay yeah he's handsome
how has he watched the show back and
what are the conversations that you all
are having because you are so close i
know jamal is my
biggest accomplishment ever in my life
right and i mean i've had a lot but he's
everything to me we watched the episodes
together and um
and he was he's really proud of me i
mean he's really proud of you know he's
really proud he's very proud of me he
helps me run my social media and
everything but like some of the episodes
were bad like that one the p i call it
the pink nightgown right he called me
and he's like mom
like what the what the hell you know i
think i know i'm so sorry you know he
was very disappointed in me he was
embarrassed because people don't think
they just don't dm me they dm him which
i don't understand why but um he was
really it was it was bad it was really
bad he was very upset with me
and i did a public apology and i did it
to us man and i did it for jamal too you
know because jamal
he doesn't he didn't deserve that
because my friend's gonna cut him out
and i don't want that to happen he's
gonna do it he's gonna cut you out like
a dog don't cost me he cannot do that no
he can't i have no business with him
he'll call me like after every episode
and be like okay so you didn't wear
makeup day but it was so hot i was so
[ __ ] santa yeah any makeup you put on
just poured off my face after a while
without makeup that was was that a thing
for that was a thing for him for your
son
yeah my son was like you need to wear
concealer
oh lord
the fact that you even had enough
confidence to do that you know without
it says a lot
thank you thank you i mean i felt it was
it was a waste of makeup and my makeup
is expensive it was a waste to put
concealer on it just melts off your face
you know right right okay um last fan
question then before we go i'll let you
say whatever you want the audience to
know um i think you'll appreciate this
question it's really thoughtful it's
from jen
jen says many people who have gone
through challenging situations use that
energy to better themselves and forge a
new chapter in their lives how has this
experience pushed you in your personal
development growth and vision for your
life
that's a really good question
i um i'm not going to take any more from
people just not i know you can't be yes
you can you can't be
nice to everybody because not everybody
appreciates your niceness nobody some
people
i've had so many people in past
relationships take take take take take
because i am a good person but once i
reach that point i like to throw in the
water once i reach that point it's just
like okay whatever you know like i i
know now who my circle is i know
that i have self-worth i know i'm a
beautiful woman regardless if it was no
makeup or not you know what i mean i
know my soul is is a i have a very good
soul and i have a very big heart
and i just will no longer let anybody
take advantage of that ever and that's
just not that's just my life now you
know and i'm not saying i'm not a bad
[ __ ] but i'm just like okay you know so
my vision in the future is to
just keep i have to be genuine because
that's just who i am that's i'm just a
genuine person and i have to
you know
for past mistakes that i've made and
everything i have to deal with that i
pray on it and i meditate on it and i
have to forgive myself because i'm my
own worst critic honey i am my own worst
critic and i just have to be me but i
have to be me at the same time you know
beautifully said kim are you still
soulja boy's number one fan i will
always be a supporter of soulja boy i
love his music i like the new song that
just came out i will always be a
supporter of his music yes i will always
be a fan always